[Music]
you're a a big guy not just a tallboy
guy but a big guy did you ever think
about playing football oh you crazy
I you know I've been blessed I haven't
had many bad days in my life I played
one football one day in my life then I
realized they were a bunch of damn
idiots okay they've just found out 30
years later you're gonna have head
issues and body issues I knew after one
day I don't want to do this every day
hey you got hit that hard you said no
this isn't happening
well you you that's all you do you I see
we got to do this again tomorrow I quit
after one day that's incredible so
you're done with that you know I have to
say you did accomplish something I don't
think I've seen any other broadcaster do
you fell asleep during a broadcast let's
take a look at that clip right now
[Applause]
what is going on you know when we do our
show we do our show from 8 o'clock at
night to 2:30 in the morning
uh-huh so obviously that's a long period
of time but the truth of the matter is
Shaq and Kenny are so damn boring I
can't tell you could blame that on Shaq
and Kidd are they so boring
I've been imagine being on television
with them in a room for six and a half
hour they're boring this is containing I
couldn't tell you good you looked very
peaceful in that long I was peaceful